"Лікар у Вашому домі".
Це не бригада швидкої допомоги.
Сімейна лікарка, хірург і його помічниця -
працівники звичайних лікарень, які приєдналися
до київської міської програми "Лікар у вашому домі".
Проект два роки тому ініціювала КМДА. Приміром,
допомагають тим, хто не може самостійно дістатися
до лікарні і відвідати профільних лікарів.
- Набряк ще є.
- Ось, ви бачите: палець укоротився і тут зігнувся.
Ользі Григорівні - 70. Вона все життя пропрацювала
вчителькою української мови. Ще до листопада
виконувала обов'язки завуча школи.
Але коли зламала плече (лікар дивиться рентген - Ред.),
її хронічна хвороба - системний червоний вовчак - почала прогресувати.
Тепер вона майже нічого не може робити самостійно.
Сімейна лікарка, з якою Ольга Григорівна
підписала декларацію, вже не могла допомогти й оформила виклик хірурга.
За програмою "Лікар у вашому домі" лікарі приїхали до пенсіонерки разом.
- По всій території України це працює за таким принципом:
сімейний лікар прийшов у свій час, вузький спеціаліст пішов  у свій час.
Можливо, вони й контактують, але кращий контакт - біля ліжка хворого.
Ідея програми "Лікар у вашому домі" у тому, що
лікарі самі йдуть до пацієнтів. У різних громадських місцях
проводяться консультації, роблять безкоштовні тести
на рівень цукру, холестерину, вимірюють тиск.
КМДА результатами задоволена: 800 людей
із майже 50 000, які пройшли обстеження в рамках програми,
були попереджені про серйозні проблеми зі здоров’ям.
Ольга Григорівна за останні 4 місяці мінімум двічі
потребувала таких консультацій, адже викликати
того ж таки хірурга або ревматолога  з поліклініки додому - нереально.
- Він не може, бо я ж бачила, скільки там людей
на прийомі у кожного хірурга. Викликали хірурга приватного.
Хірург Геннадій Ільченко у складі бригади "Лікар у вашому домі"
працює вперше. Він, як і сімейна лікарка Тетяна Трейдуб,
робить це у свій робочий час.
Додатково лікарям за виїзди не платять.
Програма не фінансується ні з міського, ні з державного бюджету.
Фактично це поєднання адміністративних ресурсів
різних лікарень із можливостями реформованої
первинної ланки медицини. Лікарям виділяють
машину для зручності пересування. Бригади
виїжджають у середньому двічі на тиждень. Утім,
встигають, звісно, далеко не всюди і не завжди вчасно.
- Таких пацієнтів багато. Я ходжу по викликах, бачу,
що твориться. Вони лежать, як неприкаяні,
догляду ніякого. Якщо є родичі нормальні, якщо
в них є гроші, то наймають доглядальницю.
Приходить хірург із приватної клініки. Це все коштує
великих грошей. А якщо нема грошей, то хоч пропадай.
Ольга Григорівна має ще двох таких, як вона,
лежачих сусідок, в яких до того ж родичі далеко від Києва.
Каже, їм для виживання вкрай необхідна якась
окрема державна медслужба, яка б опікувалася ними.
- Державне фінансування має бути.
Якась медсестра має прийти, показати, розповісти,
навіть моїм дітям, як з таким хворим, як я, поводитися.
Сімейна лікарка поспішає далі за викликом до ще одного хворого.
Потім мусить ще встигнути на прийом пацієнтів у лікарні.
- А як буває багато викликів, так ми і до 10 вечора ходимо.
Єдиної гарячої лінії програми "Лікар у вашому домі",
на жаль, немає. Хворі повинні звертатися до
сімейного лікаря, і той тоді має запланувати такий візит -
у разі потреби разом із профільним лікарем.
Медики визнають: система догляду за важкохворими в Україні
потребує докорінних реформ. Поодинокі проекти,
як от у Києві, проблеми не вирішать. Щоправда,
до цієї галузі медицини медреформа дійде не раніше 2021 року.